bouleversé ses habitudes c'est le défi
relevé par le personnel de cette
menuiserie de nouveaux rituels a adopté
dès l'arrivée sur le lieu de travail ils
iront le plan de circulation
donc il arrive par cette porte il
s'équipe après en le pays et après ils
s'intègrent leurs postes de travail
le retour c'est pareil il ya tout un
circuit justement pour pas qu'ils
croisent les personnes qui arrivent
un point important c'est qu'on a mis en
place là où aujourd'hui on travaille en
régulière pour qu'il y ait moins de
personnes à l'instant t on a ouvert en
de 8 l'ensemble du régime et puis les
personnes arrivent toutes les 10 minutes
qu'ils arrivent par deux si les salariés
de cette menuiserie ont pu reprendre le
travail le 8 avril dernier c'est parce
que pendant les trois semaines de
fermeture une équipe a planché sur la
réorganisation totale des lieux en
concertation avec le cso et la médecine
du travail 0 contact c'est dorénavant le
mot d'ordre ici un opérateur ou une
personne de bureau n'a pas à toucher une
seule poignée dans ce genre de travail
sert au contact donc c'est pour ça qu'on
voit dans le couloir c'est pour ça qu'on
voit ici toutes les portes sont
maintenues ouvertes on arrêter de
demander aux personnes de production de
batteries en arrivées et en sortie ça
évite justement de touche et sur la
validation sur une touche et
potentiellement de de contaminer de se
contaminer d'une personne à l'autre
aucun détail n'est laissé de côté
madison par exemple doit désinfecter son
poste de travail
après chaque vacation afin de brut et
qu'on appelait depuis la reprise le
petit jour on arrive ou deux en fait
au départ ce qui nous dit qu'on avait
des membres pas le plus compliqué pour
la jeune femme c'est le manque
d'interaction avec ses collègues
bahia n'a pas quoi tout simplement mais
bon après été les habitudes à prendre
pour notre sécurité en cas d'oubli
il y à michael il est l'un des référents
qu'ovide de la menuiserie sa mission
informer mais aussi rassurer les
salariés
référent colline en fin de compte a été
pour le premier jour de travail a
expliqué à chaque opérateur
comment utiliser les nouveaux
équipements comment faire pourquoi les
pauses sont des crédits et pourquoi ceci
pourquoi cela est dans le quotidien
c'est de rappeler les règles
surtout il pas oublier comme de
déconfinement va arriver que dans
l'entreprise les règles ne vont pas
évoluer
cent mille euros c'est la somme
déboursée par l'entreprise pour la mise
en place de tout le protocole de
sécurité
s'ajoutent à cela les pertes liées aux
trois semaines de fermeture en début de
confinement une facture salée pour les
menuiseries aujourd'hui on estime à peu
près une perte à 2 millions cinq
premiers ont tué tous investissements de
100 mille euros c'est une crise qui
commence à coûter cher
oui mais on espère que nous te
proactivité le pro activité notre
réactivité note anticipation de la
reprise va nous permettre de regagner
des parts de marché
certaines mesures adoptées pour faire
face à la crise sanitaire pourrait bien
perdurer dans cette menuiserie comme par
exemple le télétravail